hey guys what's up this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make the end of week update for
amc and gamestop so we're gonna see
everything that happened this week we're
gonna try to see what impact it can have
for next week where are our supports and
resistances so let's get into it
[Music]
oh right let's start with amc so guys i
did a video not long ago but let me
remind you here what i was saying
what is the situation here
so on the long term of course we are
bullish the main reason if you don't
know if you are buddhist or not just
check the 200-day moving average it's a
very good indicator if you're above you
are bullish if you're below you are
bearish okay that's for long-term view
here we are above we are bullish
everything is going well to me what i
want to focus on today is in this
corrective pattern that we are having
here we have this kind of breakout fake
out i don't know so i don't really like
what i'm seeing here so let's try to see
first if this trend line is correct
because you know sometimes trend lines
you don't need to move it a lot to
create a breakout so here
what i'm trying to see is is there any
trend line close to this one that is not
creating this breakout and i'm gonna
force it i'm gonna try to you know i'm
putting it here and i'm trying to
connect the laws i'm having here so i'm
you know cheating a little bit just to
see how it looks and it's acceptable
okay the issue i have is that i don't
match the slow and here it's not perfect
and here either so definitely this
bracket this trend line is not as good
as this one that is to me the right one
but is still acceptable so if we have a
strong bounce this would be the trend
line that i would use so it's still
interesting to see that there is a
situation where we don't have a breakout
but for now we do have this breakout
then if we zoom in a little bit
i'm gonna then tell you what is what it
means for next week but first if we zoom
a little bit on the hourly time frame so
i'm gonna put back the trend line
it moved a little bit
okay so it's like this right now i'm
matching here here here and here i'm not
matching perfectly here but i'm matching
here here and here so it's the good
trend line to watch on the hourly
timeframe and here we can see guys that
we have this breakout first then he
rejected and yesterday we went to 36.5
which is right now the level this is
going higher that we need to trade above
to be back in the triangle ascending
triangle we drew here
and we got rejected so i mean it's not
looking great right but i have some good
news guys
i have some good news as i was saying uh
on my discord we have here
an interesting candle formation look let
me get rid of that well moving basically
lower every day since the 19th of
october
and here in the past two days look what
we're having those are doji candles so
the first one is not really perfect the
body is still big
we have a small tail on the downside and
a bigger tail on the upside but it's not
a very nice dodgy candle either to be a
perfect dodgy candle it needs to be very
small or on the other side very long and
here we have a long-legged doji so what
it what does it mean it means that bulls
and bears were fighting all day long uh
making new laws making new eyes and in
the end at the end of the day it came
back to where it all started still in
green which means bulls won this day
it's a small victory but it's still a
victory the day before was a victory too
so we have two days in a row we have
those kind of dodgy candles won by the
bulls guys we should be in an area
controlled by bears if this is really a
breakout
so
this breakout is not looking good i mean
it's not looking like a strong breakout
for this reasons
first no volume okay so whenever you
have a breakout you absolutely need to
check the volume i mean it would get rid
maybe of 80 percent of your breakouts
you would be left with 20 of them but
those 20
would be
working very well here it's not a good
breakout because as you guys can see
what i mean by volume you need to have
at least twice or three times the volume
traded in the past week in average okay
the average daily volume here you can
see on this day we broke out
the volume is even lower so first reason
to have a fake out second reason to
dodgy candle that closed in green
and i can find a trend line that is not
perfect but that is fitting with this
lows
so my take is that bulls are taking back
control and
once again to take fully back control we
need to get back in this ascending
triangle territory around 36 37 now it's
going higher every day but it's looking
quite good to me the alternative
scenario you get you guys need to be
aware of is that bears take back control
we make a red day and you know we have
support here at 33.5
so maybe we're gonna rebound here but
then this breakout would be i mean of
course validated and the worst thing
that could happen to me but still guys
it's important that be prepared for
every scenario so that you don't panic
you're not scared i mean if it's part of
the plan it's fine and here
you need to be aware that if we close
below 33.5 we might go to 30 okay and
then we'll probably bounce you know so
just be prepared for this scenario it's
not my preferred scenario but it's
something that can happen so we need to
be prepared my preferred scenario is
that we come back here guys all right
so let's see what is happening now let's
go to gme
all right so gme is showing much better
signs
i like jimmy it's really
you know a good example of
how it looks when bulls are fighting
bears and
bulls are controlling what is happening
i mean
okay let's let me explain so
first
we are in the same kind of environment
in the ascending triangle but here gme
is already on the 200-day moving average
which is a strong support which is
supporting the price for the past week
all right you can see we never closed uh
below that
we played with it again on that day but
we closed above
and since then we are moving we're
grinding higher and look guys what i'm
really paying attention to is this trend
line all right this streamline is very
important because
as you can see one two three four
five six seven eight reaction
reactions on the daily but if i go on
the hourly time frame
okay so i need to move a little bit
because i have here extended trading
hours okay look at that guys
it's almost broken actually and look in
the past week
how many times we tested it once twice
three four five six seven eight i cannot
even count guys we are totally on it all
right especially yesterday this is
actually almost confirmed on the hourly
time frame i'm just looking at it right
now and what i like is to see this
consolidation this is something you guys
can remember this is something that is
working well whenever you you see the
price action consolidating so you can
spot that using bollinger bands for
example let me just show you so
bollinger bands
all right
and you can see
that on the daily time frame it's now a
ring
so we like to see that let's then zoom
on the fourth time frame not obvious on
the first time frame and on the hourly
time frame
okay
more obvious on the hourly time frame
so you can see here we are really
narrowing here we were
just like here okay you can see here it
was very narrow and then we had the move
and now we are never going again
so
i think that you know this is usually
what you're having in those build up
areas where buyers
actually accumulate some long positions
let me get rid of it and this is exactly
what is happening so let me come back to
what i was saying whenever you have a
consolidation just below a level a
resistance level that has been tested
many times especially in the recent past
it's bullish especially if you have
increasing volumes and look at what
we're having here from the fourth time
frame clearly the volumes are increasing
all right so this is good okay we have
increasing volumes we're getting close
to the breakout it's good and on the
daily
volumes are stable so what is happening
here so two scenarios first my preferred
scenarios we built up enough energy to
just break out maybe we're gonna have a
retest and then we're gonna run to this
area to 30 where here we might be
rejected first and play this little game
again let's see okay
but
the alternative scenario once again is
that you know we do one more one more
small like thing and then we break out
so this is possible as well we are on
the resistance level right now so bears
might try to do something
i'm looking at anc chart as well besmar
tried to do something as well so
my preferred scenario is that we go
higher right away but my alternative
scenario is that we make one more small
dip and then we break it okay and
the alternative alternative scenario
once again let's just be prepared if we
break the 200-day moving average to be
honest i don't want to be prepared for
this scenario because it's not a nice
one but if we do break that what could
happen
what could happen guys nothing too bad i
mean
it wouldn't be nice it could take for
four more time
first we could fake out 165 is the first
support if we break 165 would probably
go to the 140 area and then bounce
so this is my take uh once again i do
believe we build up enough energy to
break out now if we do close above 185
let's call it like this 184 anytime
during the week the day after what i
think is that booze are going to jump in
massively in the trade so let's find out
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys